did it not seem odd to you though that  your brother would share a bed or have  slumber parties with young children  I don't know psi I can't say yes when  you said sleepovers right yeah I think I  grew up in it so for me it wasn't odd  you know I think to the outside world  yes I think it can be odd I mean I'm not  oblivious to what it sounds like but  when you're actually there in that  atmosphere and you're around it and  you're watching movies was kids - yes  with his kids whether it's little  rascals or Three Stooges and you're  watching these things it's like it's  very innocent but I think the fault of  my uncle was he just he didn't have that  bone in his body  to look at it the other way and I think  that was the thing is that his naivety  was his downfall  in a way